i haven't been to the movie theaters in
years
in years you know because we're d
streaming watching things on amazon
prime netflix whatever but
this movie i had to see in the theater
because it's tom cruise it brought her
back tom cruise is trending tonight
because of his return to the sky
top gun maverick premiering at several
local theaters tonight many lining up
early at town square to be the first to
see it some even showing up in costume
possibly inspired by ted's comments
earlier military families getting a
chance to check out all the action early
thanks to a las vegas theater yeah art
house downtown holding a special event
for those out at nellis and creech air
force bases so they can see this movie
based on their real life work sasha
loftus in studio she was there and
joining us now live with more
brandon denise we are all excited to see
this movie but for our local military
members it's even more meaningful they
tell me it's great to have their work
represented and understood in such a
cool way
are you ready for the danger zone
our local military certainly is it
really makes it come together for what i
do dozens from both nellis and creech
air force base gathered thursday to get
their first glimpse of top gun maverick
i'm seeing like how closely it does
relate to like hearing like their calms
and stuff and like i'm like oh i know
that brevity art house theater and ngl
group hosted an event downtown for air
force families to catch a special
showing of the movie we've all been
waiting for it's an air force movie we
have air force base in town this latest
top gun installment was pushed back
twice because of the kovitt 19 pandemic
and shawn barrick managing partner of
art house theaters says its release
really symbolizes a rebound it's been
great seeing a lot more people come back
to the theater come back to food and
beverage come back to the entertainment
experience as for those actually living
like maverick they said it's great to
see their line of work represented on
the big screen to be able to see
some appreciation to the members of the
military who sacrificed their time and
parts of their lives
that's that's pretty cool as they get a
front row seat to all the action having
any fun yet
now fun fact for you the real top gun
school that the movie is based on is
called the naval fighter weapons school
it used to be based in california but it
is now located in fallon nevada which is
about six hours north of here yeah they
did uh they shot some in nevada desert
and in california right yeah the first
top gun in from the 80s they apparently
they shot some of it in fallon which was
pretty cool so kind of a nevada
connection there guess who's seeing it
tomorrow morning brian loftis coffee
maverick he's all excited about it yeah
he's been talking about it yeah forget
cereal going right for the popcorn
around the entire newsroom who's seeing
top gun when i showed my daughters the
original from i believe 1986 last week
and they are fully prepped and prepared
and now tomorrow we have the new one and
from those clips it looks amazing it
looks so good can't wait